[Music]
you gonna spend a certain amount of time
practicing getting the white in the
pocket so I thought I would design again
and I've called the game loop because
it's loop so it's pull but different and
also because it is a loop what I
realized when I was coming up with games
is to play it with a small number of
balls it's much more fun than with a
large number of balls you have a black
it's not pit there you have two colors
like this and you're the cue ball it's a
two-player game and the aim is you've
got to get a color in and then you've
got to get the black in starting for
cueing off you put the cue ball
somewhere in the line between the black
in here and you were to say which ball
is gonna be the one you're gonna go for
so let's I go for red and then here we
go okay this is a hypothetical position
I got to get the red in the pocket I
can't hit the side here because the
blacks in the way so what you need to do
is you I need to hit this red ball so it
rebounds and goes in how do I know where
to hit it well I can use the focus point
because if I hit the red in such a way
that it goes in that direction I know
it's going to rebound and go in so I
need to hit the red ball exactly in that
way so I need to hit it like that
because if it's coming from there it
will go in now give it a try but I wish
I would get it because I'm really bad
pool player I guess I need to well is it
gonna go in it didn't work well you get
good at this when you understand how it
works that is how to do it and it just
opens up lots of really fun patterns of
play basically the trick is whenever you
play you've got to be thinking about
this dot and how things will happen if
they
from this dot and that's the kind of the
axis that you use to pot all the pot all
the Bulls so you're trying to get the
red ball in I will get the red ball in
one side on the red ball in I will then
go for the black ball
I'll get the black ball in then the
moment the black balls in the pocket I
have one so I'm going to challenge your
nephew Jacob to a game of loop I'm
getting read it so it's you you need to
you need to go for the yellow and thing
is what you know is if you hit the
yellow so that the yellow goes exactly
through here you know it's gonna rebound
into there but you need to not only
begin to hit it in this direction you
need to hit it at just the right force
so not too hot not too cold
oh it's really good that's really good
that was your first ever time that you
hit it with a bit of practice you would
get that in Oh what you need to do now
you've got to try and find a way of
getting that in if you hit that yellow
as if it's coming from there it's gonna
hit that and you don't run think it
ships go straight in there
[Music]
what you see is that there is a tendency
for the balls to start at the center and
to go around and so you also need to
start to think about reposition trying
to reposition the balls in the center
but what I would to try and do to get
this in so this is a snooker and loop
and it's called a snoop
yeah there's no way I'm gonna be able to
get there so I'm just gonna move this to
here oh you need to hit the yellow ball
as if it's hit by the white ball coming
from the focus points so as if it's
coming in this direction here and then
that will hit it rebound there so you
need to play yes yeah yeah but then it's
your hands gonna hit the head that
[Music]
that's skill yeah the thing is there's
only been one game of it so far what
happens if you pop the keyboard it's not
to even lusts you've lost on the black
you lost oh that's that's the rules of
pool so it meant then you've lost any
blast that's a lot yeah I think the
black is that's what I was a pull yeah
[Music]
I hit it too hard but I was on the money
history history
[Laughter]
[Music]